hi guys Dr Berg here in this video I
want to talk about an interesting
vitamin B1 and its deficiencies this is
very common and uh it's quite
interesting because it's actually a
helper factor or a helper vitamin in
three main enzymes that have to do with
carbohydrates now when someone switches
over to a ketogenic diet um the whole
mechanism of burning fat in the
mitochondria um it needs a lot of B1 so
you also need B1 in fat metabolism as
well so here are the symptoms number one
nervous energy like this buildup of
nervous energy like you're going to
explode or you're just very restless you
can't relax okay that's number one
number two edema or swelling in your
calf when you have enough B1 you don't
accumulate fluid okay B1 also is
connected to the heart as well um
numbness tingling in the hands are or
feet that relates to diabetes simply
because B1 is involved in the production
of myin the surrounding covering of the
nerves so when you don't have B1 because
you had too much sugar it strips off
that and you start having neurological
problems okay number four increase heart
heart rate now potassium also keeps the
heart in check but also B1 does as well
um probably because the electrical um
connection to the heart uh number five
restless legs now you try to sleep and
you're pound your legs I had this
problem for years I would literally get
up in the middle of the night and pound
my legs and go exercise to try to get
this energy out because it was driving
me nuts so what's happening is you have
this retention of lactic acid like after
a workout you're going to have L lactic
acid and it's going to actually keep the
uh energy into the lower part of the
legs that's a B1 deficiency B1 helps
release that lactic acid it can also
improve recovery time after
exercise next one seasickness or car
sickness if you have that take more B1
that will help you uh nightmares if you
have nightmares or vivid dreams or your
kids have nightmares give them vitamin
B1 that is the solution um air hunger so
let's say
you're Can't Get Enough air now it could
be that your pH is too acid or like in
lactic acidosis or high lactic acid or
it could be that you're just B1
deficient okay so another remedy for
that so now what causes B1 deficiencies
number one sugar okay hidden sugars
refined grains hidden sugars like juice
things like that alcohol will do it
liver damage like therosis or a fatty
liver because you need the liver to
metabolize a lot of these B vitamins
stress will deplete B1 caffeine will do
it um that would be like in tea as well
too much of it birth control pills
anti-acids okay so what is the solution
number one cut the sugar out the grains
the alcohol uh stress right cut down the
caffeine and add nutritional yeast to
the diet make sure that's unfortified
nutritional yeast because they put
synthetic vitamins in there I don't
recommend taking synthetic vitamins
unless you're doing a detox but as a
maintenance get the natural ones or
concentrated nutritional yeast thanks
for watching hey if you haven't already
subscribed press this little button down
below okay thanks